Want to hear something awesome? Of
course you do. How about hearing from
hundreds of ex-Muslims in dozens of
countries around the world? That's what
we're about to do. And as we hear from
ex-Muslims, we're going to mark the
countries they're from on a map so we
can see what the global map of apostasy
looks like. Why are we doing this? Well,
I was on Matt Frad's podcast recently.
We talked for over 3 hours. One of the
things we talked about was the
skyrocketing apostasy rates in Islam.
But whenever I bring this up, I always
see people in the comments asking,
"Well, if so many Muslims are leaving
Islam, why does it look like Islam is
taking over entire cities in Europe? Why
does it look like Islam is growing?"
Islam taking over in places like London
is a completely different issue. Islam
is growing globally because Muslims have
higher birth rates than other groups.
Muslim women and girls are married off
at a younger age. They often have fewer
opportunities for education or careers
and they end up having more babies than
non-Muslim women. That's why the numbers
are growing. Islam is expanding in the
West due primarily to immigration. So,
high birth rates and immigration, but
those are separate issues from the
apostasy rates, the numbers of Muslims
who are leaving Islam and becoming
Christians or atheists or agnostics or
something else. [snorts] 20 years ago,
it was rare to hear from an ex-Muslim.
Today, ex-Muslims are everywhere. Why?
Because the apostasy rates are going
through the roof and Muslim leaders are
in panic mode because they know that
even though they still have the highest
birth rates, their birth rates are
declining while the apostasy rates are
accelerating.
Muslim leaders are doing the math. The
math doesn't lie and it spells disaster
for Islam.
>> 24% of Muslim youth are leaving Islam.
Previously according to me when an when
a person from Saudi Arabia or from the
Gulf country went to America or went to
western country the chances that you
know they would deviate from their dein
would be maybe 1 or 2% that's it but
nowadays the chances are more than 25%.
>> And if we don't take constructive steps
to deal with this
it is going to become an avalanche.
So, don't focus on where things are.
Focus on where things are heading. Now,
let's do something fun. I posted a video
last month and the comment section is
filled with ex-Muslims and it's awesome
because a bunch of them mentioned the
countries they're from. I don't know how
that became a thing, but I like it. Just
so you can see how many ex-Muslims there
are and where they're leaving Islam,
we're going to read some of the comments
on one video. These are all comments on
a single video. And again, as we call
out the countries, we'll mark the
countries on a map. Let's start with
Afghanistan.
I am a Hazara from Afghanistan. I left
Islam over 10 years ago. ex-Muslim from
Afghanistan and I'm very happy for my
people to leave Islam. I'm Afghan and
I've left and became Christian. My
mother, aunt, and grandfather did, too.
We all see through the darkness Islam
brings to this world and won't be part
of that. Ex-Muslim from Afghanistan
living in the West here. Salute, David.
You are awesome. True. I am from the US
but I have an Afghan friend who lives in
Sweden. His whole family converted to
Christianity when coming to the west.
Ex-Muslim from Afghanistan right now but
stuck there. I can't announce it
publicly. You know why. I am also Afghan
ex-Muslim. Want to become Zaratustrian.
Love my Persian past. But just so you
know, Jesus is Lord everywhere. I know
for a fact that many are leaving Islam
in Afghanistan. Hallelujah. I'm from
Afghanistan and I leave Islam because if
you are in doubt about what we have
revealed to you, ask those who read the
scripture before you. Jesus is the word,
spirit, and Lord. He's referring to
surah 10 verse 94 of the Quran where
Allah tells Muhammad that he can only
confirm his revelations by checking with
Jews and Christians to make sure his
revelations line up with our
revelations. So the Quran confirms the
Bible. Looks like we can definitely add
Afghanistan to our map of apostates.
Next up, Pakistan.
I am an ex-Muslim from Pakistan now
Christian. I am Pakistani ex-Muslim and
now it's almost three years I have left
Islam and accepted Jesus Christ as my
Lord and Savior. Thank you Jesus for
saving me and the world. I had a Muslim
co-orker from Pakistan. Great guy who
left Islam after becoming friends with
Christian Americans. Pakistani ex-Muslim
here. Thank you Jesus for saving me. I
am Pakistani Christian. Many Muslims
listen to the gospel, but they don't
show their faith in public for security
reasons. God bless you, David. I'm an
ex-Muslim from Pakistan four years ago
and now an atheist. Atheist? How did
that make sense? Ex-Muslim from
Pakistan. Was an atheist for a while,
then an agnostic for a longer while. And
now I'm slowly making my way to the King
of Kings, Jesus Christ. read the gospel
of John and Mark so far. Perfect start
if you want to learn about Jesus.
Ex-Muslim from Pakistan. Pakistan.
Pakistan. Pakistan.
Pakistan. Your apostates have put you on
the map. Next up, Turkey. Can anything
good come from there? Let's find out.
Ex-Muslim from Turkey. A lot of Turks
become agnostics. Ex-Muslim from Turkey
here. Now Christian. Jesus Christ is the
Lord. Orthodox Christian here. I have
two friends who were Muslims with
Turkish heritage. Both left Islam some 5
years ago and will get baptized on Holy
Mount Aos in Greece. Glory to God.
Ex-Muslim from Turkey here and I have
met so many Turkish ex-Muslims.
just left Islam like a week ago from
Turkey and I can say with absolute
conviction that Turkey won't be a Muslim
majority country by 2100. A huge
percentage of the youth are abandoning
Islam. Now I can easily say ex-Muslim
from Turkey. My religion high school was
full of children that were hiding that
they have abandoned Islam from their
parents. I am an ex-Muslim from Turkey.
I am recently being interested in
Christianity but afraid of being
isolated from society. Grew up in a
Turkish Muslim family. I am now a
Christian. Ex-Muslim from Turkey.
Turkey. Turkey. Turkey. Turkey tried to
exterminate its Christian population.
But now we're going to see Islam crumble
in Turkey in our lifetimes. You're on
the map, Turkey. On to the next. Iraq.
But first, let's hear a brief word about
this video's sponsor. Christmas is right
around the corner, but you don't need to
wait until the last minute, running from
store to store trying to find a present
for your spouse or friend. Artza has you
covered. Artza has launched their brand
new Christmas box called Nativity Night,
and it's their most incredible box yet.
Every year, the Christmas box sells out
faster and faster. And this year,
because of huge demand, they're almost
gone. Each item in your Artsa box is
handmade by local artisans and small
family businesses in places like
Nazareth and Jerusalem and Bethlehem.
So, when you sign up with Artsa, you're
blessing and supporting these artisans
and families while bringing the land of
the Bible right into your home or
someone else's home. Inside there's an
awesome handpainted ceramic plate
depicting the night of the nativity,
delicious foods and spices, a beautiful
handcarved olivewood nativity ornament
from Bethlehem, and other handcrafted
treasures that bring the story of
Christmas to life. So help a friend or
loved one experience Christmas this year
with a box of gifts straight from the
land where Jesus walked. They're only
selling this box for a few more days and
it's almost sold out. Plus, they just
increased our discount. You'll get 15%
off with the promo code dizzle. So, this
is the perfect gift to celebrate
Christmas and share the beauty of the
Holy Land with your loved ones. Click
the link in the description box and get
one today. Now, back to Iraq. I'm an
ex-Muslim from Iraq. I left Islam from
15 years ago, and many youth now leave
Islam continuously. Ex-Muslims from
Iraq. Ex-Muslim from Iraq. Let's add
Iraq to the map. How about Bosnia?
Ex-Muslim from Bosnia. I have an online
friend from Iraq that wants to be
Christian. Is there a way to help him
get out of Iraq and go to a Christian
country or a country where he will not
be killed by Muslims? Look up one of the
ministries that helps people in this
situation. Check out Open Doors and
World Relief. Born into a Bosnian Muslim
family. I am getting baptized next
month. Ex-Muslim and new Christian here.
Born in Bosnia but grew up in America.
Ex-Muslim from Bosnia. David, you're
doing great. I'm Bosnian ex-Muslim who
converted to Serbian Christian Orthodox
following my ancestors true religion. We
can add Bosnia to the map of apostasy.
Now for India, ex-Muslim from India
since 2018. Ex-Muslim from India.
Ex-Muslim from Kerala India. Ex-Muslim
from India. Ex-Muslim from Bangalore,
India. Now an agnostic. Thank you David
Apostate Prophet and Hara Sultan and all
the atheist organization who is exposing
this death cult. Ex Sunni Muslim from
Mumbai, India had a divine encounter
with Lord Jesus Christ at age five on
Ramadan aid morning prayer. Does our God
have a sense of humor or what? 55 years
ago, now in ministry for the past 35
years. Glory to God my father. Lord
Jesus, my savior and my sweet best
friend, the Holy Spirit of Almighty God.
Thank you, Jesus. Love. PS. David Wood.
He is the best. Thank you, Jesus, for
him and his team of apologists. God
bless them. Join us for intercession on
Issa MSI TV. Proud ex-Muslim from
Kerala, India. ex-Muslim from India.
From memorizing the complete Quran to
now laughing at the obvious Zabiba
worshipping book. Especially thanks to
you, David. God bless you. God bless
you. Ex-Muslim from India. Ex-Muslim
from India. Ex-Muslim from Ukril, India.
My wife is an ex-Muslim from India. She
found Christ. Ex-Muslim here. Left
recently for Christ from India
Northeast. Left Islam during COVID and
accepted Hinduism from India. Ex-Muslim
from India. Ex-Muslim from Kolkata,
India. Ex from West Bengal, India.
Ex-Muslims from Hindustan, India are
growing in mass. Ex-Muslim from India.
I'm an ex-Muslim from India. Thanks to
Adam Seeker, Erdo and ex-Muslim Sahil.
Ex-Muslim from India. I'm watching you
since 2015, David. And because of
curiosity about pig status in Islam, it
took me 5 years to move away from that
extremist ideology, Hera Sultan and
Ridan Idmir helped me too. From Bombay,
ex-Muslim from India. In India,
approximately 40 million ex-Muslims. You
might not believe that Kerala in India
has more than 300,000
ex-Muslims. They have an organization
named Ex-Muslims of Kerala. Ex-Muslim
here. Proud to be Mortad. Let's add
India to the apostate map. Next up,
Iran. Ex-Muslims from Iran. Ex-Muslim
from Iran here. Became a follower of
Christ 3 years ago. Hallelujah. I'm an
ex-Muslim who converted to Christianity
and I know more than 5,000 ex-Muslims
from Iran to the grace and glory of our
Lord and Savior Jesus Christ. Amen. I'm
Iranian and I'm living in Iran. To say
that a million Iranians left Islam is a
massive understatement. Iran's
population is 90 million. Among this
population, at least 20 to 30% of people
claim to be non-Muslims and criticize
Islam very harshly. Something around 50%
of the population doesn't really call
themselves Muslims. Still, they don't
mind much about Muslims and think all
the harsh things you hear about radical
Muslims are not the real Islam. mainly
because of the massive propaganda that
the Islamic regime in power here
spreads. Among the rest of the
population that openly claims to be
Muslim, very few of them are the kind
that go to mosque and pray five times a
day. Mosques are actually very empty
these days. Islam ruined my beautiful
country. Don't let that happen to yours.
P.S. among all the population in the
country, at least 80% oppose Sharia and
don't want it anymore.
Ex-Muslim from Iran. And I'm telling
you, million million Iranians are
leaving this religion. Ex-Muslim from
Iran. Ex-Muslim from Iran. Ex-Muslim
from Iran. Lord opened up my eyes since
2004. I am a Christian. Proudly praise
our Lord and Savior Jesus Christ. I
remember visiting the Middle East a few
years ago and met a guy in Iran who was
doing baptisms down south. It was wild
when we talked about it and I got to
visit one of the events. Apparently,
there are hundreds a week in one town
and I remember seeing a dozen new
churches built. Ex-Muslim from Iran here
since 2020. Though I'm a Zoroastrian
like many other patriotic young
Iranians. Ex-Muslim from Iran. Jesus
saved me from depression that I had for
13 years. I've been taking medicine
since I was 12, but have never been
healed. I turned away from Allah when I
was 20 years old because I took a deeper
look at Islamic teachings and especially
studied the Quran. It was clearly
man-made. Slowly found out about Jesus
Christ and asked him to give me a sign.
Then the Holy Spirit reached me when I
was at my lowest. My father is Iranian
ex-Muslim. Ex-Muslim from Iran. I know
no one that still believes in Islam here
anymore. We are the pioneers of this
movement. I guess our church is
baptizing several Iranians every year,
it seems. Guess we can add Iran to the
map. But I know what you guys want. I
know what you want. Saudi Arabia. An
ex-Muslim from strong Muslim country
like Saudi Arabia. Thanks. Ex-Muslim
from Saudi Arabia and I don't regret
Jesus saved and changed my life.
Ex-Muslim here from Saudi Arabia.
Ex-Muslim from Mecca. Ex-Muslims from
Saudi Arabia. Saudi here. I memorized
the entire Quran when I was 11 years old
and I never had any connection or awe or
goosebumps or anything. Just a bunch of
random words that were gibberish. And
the book dares say it is clear. And the
infuriating thing is the kirat on top of
memorizing the words I had to speak them
in certain way not plain Arabic. That's
why when I had my own independence when
I was 13, I never looked back on
anything Islamic. Of course, I was
Muslim and I will kill to defend it, but
not practicing Muslim. No prayer, no
Quran, nothing until 2023 when I
stumbled on your channel and many
Christians channels that I started to
learn the truth. Of course, the only
reason that I even entertained the
thought of watching you is because I was
always fascinated by Christianity, that
I couldn't resist what your thoughts
process about Islam. I had always seen
famous people say it's a religion of
peace. So, I clicked and that simple
choice changed everything about my life,
about my morality, my thought process,
about the world and what's right and
what's wrong, about a true connection
with the true living God. I thank you
David for on the beginning of this year
after two years of continuous internal
battle with myself I rested my life in
the hands of the Lord and I am grateful
to the Lord for my life to begin so lost
in the darkness and to meet the source
of the truth and light in my lowest
point of my life because without him I
will be nothing more than a soulless
husk without a connection to a god that
makes certain that in the end there is
purpose in life before your first video
I saw I watched atheists and I resonate
with them and I apostate far quicker.
But couple days later, I saw how stupid
it was and returned Muslim. Of course,
that ordeal was because I was under so
much grief and pain. I rebelled against
the Islamic God for the injustice.
Anyway, this is my testimony. Thank you
again, David, and God bless you. Glad we
could help. And I'm glad we can add
Saudi Arabia to the map. Now for South
Africa. I'm Christian. My husband is now
ex-Muslim. He got baptized last year.
South Africa. Praise Jesus. Ex-Muslim
from South Africa. Left Islam last year.
Best decision I've made of my life.
Ex-Muslim from South Africa. Now preach
and teach the gospel. Best decision
ever. South Africa. We found a place for
you on our map of apostasy. Next up,
Bangladesh. I'm an ex-Muslim and an
agnostic now. I left Islam in June 2024,
and it's been the best decision of my
life. But sadly, I can't be public about
my apostasy as I live in Bangladesh.
Ex-Muslim from Bangladesh, ex-Muslim
from Bangladesh, ex-Muslim from
Bangladesh. I am an ex-Muslim from
Bangladesh, ex-Muslim from Bangladesh,
ex-Muslim from Bangladesh. Here I wanted
to convert to Christianity but the local
churches are not cooperating. Bangladesh
is a country which is extremely hostile
towards non-Muslims. The churches here
do not want to take the risk. It seems
I've heard that about some of the
churches in Bangladesh. I'm an ex-Muslim
from Bangladesh. Christ saved my life.
Ex-Muslim from Bangladesh. Ex-Muslim
from Bangladesh. Ex-Muslim from
Bangladesh. I'm from Bangladesh and I
know the situations here. If local
churches convert Muslims, then radical
Muslims target churches and Christians.
Why are Muslims so afraid?
Ex-Muslim from Bangladesh. Bangladesh.
Bangladesh. Bangladesh. Bangladesh.
Bangladesh is definitely on our map, but
churches need to figure out a way to
help the ex-Muslim Christians. Now for
Egypt. Egypt. Ex-Muslim from Egypt
around seven to eight years ago became a
follower of Christ four months ago.
Internet is the best thing to happen to
Muslims. Worst thing to happen to Islam.
Christ is Lord. I was born a Muslim in
Egypt, but I chose Jesus. I can't change
the fact that my Egyptian legal
documents say I'm Muslim, but I will
never give up Jesus. Ex-Muslim from
Egypt. Ex-Muslim from Egypt. Ex-Muslim
from Egypt. Jesus is Lord. Jesus is God.
Jesus is Jehovah. Amen. I'm an ex-Muslim
from Egypt and living in Canada. So, we
can add Egypt. And we can't forget the
country with the most Muslims in the
world, Indonesia. As an Indonesian, I
can confirm that many Muslims are
becoming Christians, including some of
my best friends. The Islamic community
tried to counter this by promoting those
muallafs, new Muslim converts from other
religions, especially Christianity, on
the media, especially celebrities, but
they couldn't contain the underground
Muslim to Christian conversions. Even
government official statistics finally
began to show the reality of slowly
shifting demography, especially in
Central and East Java, the most populous
area of Indonesia. Ex-Muslim from
Indonesia. My husband is ex-Muslim too
from Indonesia. Ex-Muslim from
Indonesia. I went to Madrasa my whole
life. And the internet has been the best
part to confirm my discomfort on
Muhammad, especially about marrying a
child. I was baptized and now free and
seen as a whole human, not a property or
my voice is half to a man. God bless
you, David. Indonesia here is huge
Muslim leaving Islam. Indonesian
ex-Muslim. I'm one of those Indonesian
media. Not sure how to pronounce this.
Rami Uba Colum Agama KTP. Meaning many
people are changing the religion column
on their ID cards. People are leaving
Islam on mass in Indonesia. I live in
Indonesia and believe it or not, Mr.
David, Muslim youths in this age don't
really care about Islam. People's
mindsets here are either traditional or
western. Islam is almost nothing but a
tradition here instead of a religious
belief. I am Christian from Indonesia.
Many of my Muslim friends, they don't
practice Islam, but in their KTP ID card
still say Islam for they don't want to
get bullied by other Muslims in their
community. So in a way they are
ex-Muslim but still claim they are
Muslim KTP only. ex-Muslim from
Indonesia and leaving Islam and Muhammad
and Allah forever and ever because
Muhammad is not saving you from hell.
Only Jesus, the only one savior and God.
Hallelujah. In my country, the largest
Muslim, Islam, predominantly Indonesia,
an avalanche of Muslims leaving Islam is
also happening thanks to the internet
and the many apologetic programs.
ex-Muslim since 2011 from Indonesia.
Ex-Muslim from Indonesia here left Islam
in 2018. God bless you all. I'm
Indonesian. I confirm that for the last
several years, many Indonesian Muslims
left Islam for Christianity due to hard
works from Indonesian young YouTube, Tik
Tok apologists like Edis TV, Agatha
Polalmo, Eliia Myron, Bang RK and more.
The statement of millions Indonesian
Muslims leaving Islam, either becoming
atheists, agnostics, or converting to
Christianity is not quite exaggerated.
The truth is it might even be bigger.
How do you know that? The social media
channels, YouTube, Instagram, Tik Tok,
whatever, just showed so many so-called
meraden channels, meaning doing mtad,
aka leaving Islam. This is probably why
the two biggest Muslim communities
Nadlatul Ulma and Muhammadia are
panicking even fighting each other.
Ex-Muslim from Indonesia from 3 years
ago, born as a Muslim and raised in a
conservative Muslim family and
environment, going to Islamic school
since kindergarten up until high school.
The doctrine was too deep that it took
10 years for me to leave Islam. After
taking that decision, everything is just
bliss and peaceful. We love having
Indonesia on the list and we love seeing
the United Kingdom. Ex-Muslim in the UK.
I started my channel to contribute to
the Exodus. Ex-Muslim of 23 years in the
UK. To all the newbies, glad you could
join me. Ex-Muslim from the UK. I know
at least nine ex-Muslims in my circle in
the UK. And my circle is not huge. I
assume that in the UK alone there are
hundreds of thousands of ex-Muslims.
would love to see statistics. I'm from
East London, near where that huge mosque
is. I'm Christian now. Islam was just
forced on me. So, the United Kingdom is
on the map. Next up, Syria. Here, Syrian
ex-Muslim since 2023. Be strong. Don't
show weakness about your decision.
Ex-Muslim from Syria. I am a Syrian
Christian. I only know myself. There are
about 300 secret Syrian Christians who
are only named and cannot be baptized or
share their faith except over the
internet. Ex-Muslim from Syria. Syria is
on the map. Now we have Algeria.
Ex-Muslim from Algeria. Ex-Muslim from
Algeria. Here ex-Muslim from Algeria.
Ex-Muslim from Algeria. Christ is King.
Algeria is on the apostasy map. and so
is Albania. Ex Albanian Muslim around 8
years ago. I converted 2 years ago to
Christianity when my husband told me
about the gospel and Jesus. When I was
agnostic, many people were less likely
to care that I was an ex-Muslim until I
converted to Christianity. Then I saw
crazy reactions from people. Ex-Muslim
from Albania. Returning to the faith of
my ancestors before Islamic Ottoman
conquerors forced us to convert.
Ex-Muslim from Albania. Albania is on
the map. We normally see bad news about
Nigeria. News about the persecution of
Christians. But here's some good news.
Ex-Muslim from northern Nigeria. I've
been a Christian for 8 years. Even
though I was kicked out by my family,
but it's worth it. I was lost but now
I'm found. Ex-Muslim from Nigeria. I
love Jesus so much. This is true. A lot
of Muslims in Nigeria have converted to
Christianity. Most especially in the
southwestern part of Nigeria. Among the
Yoruba tribe, Muslims are leaving Islam
for Christianity. I'm from Nigeria. Many
Muslims are converting in mass. Mostly
people from the southwest, Yoruba
people. No wonder recently here in
Nigeria, most shakes and Islamic clerics
have been asking our government to
control the internet, calling it
harmful. You can try to stop the
avalanche, shakes, but Nigeria is on the
map now for Morocco. Ex-Muslim from
Morocco. Jesus saved me through dreams
and visions. Hallelujah. Jesus is Lord.
Ex-Muslim from Morocco. Ex-Muslim from
Morocco. Ex-Muslim from Morocco. Christ
is Lord. So, we've got Morocco, but we
can't forget Lebanon. Ex-Muslim from
Lebanon for over 10 years, became
Christian last year. Jesus Christ is
Lord. I'm Lebanese and grew up in a
strict Muslim household. My brother
moved out at 17 and was ostracized from
the family and community. For years, we
didn't know anything about him. Later
on, he reconnected with my mom. He had
gone to Bible school and today he is a
pastor. Later on both me and my older
brother converted to Christianity and my
other two brothers no longer practice or
believe in Islam. My childhood friend is
a Muslim and her mom had a dream about
Jesus and my friend had also felt his
presence. Now she's buying a Bible and
her family is learning about
Christianity. Praise the Lord. We're so
many more than you could imagine. So, we
can add Lebanon, but you probably didn't
know about Kurdistan. Ex-Muslim here
from Kurdistan. I think Christianity is
the best religion. Ex-Muslim Kurd living
in Germany. Ex-Muslim from Kurdistan.
Kurdish. Ex-Muslim here. Ex-Muslim from
Kurdistan. My buddy is an Iraqi Kurdish
refugee. He left Islam when ISIS was a
thing. He's an atheist now, but open to
Christ. Pray he finds him. Lots of
ex-Muslims in Kurdistan. Not on the map
though because it's not a separate
country. Now for Kazakhstan.
Ex-Muslims from Kazakhstan here. With
love from Kazakhstan from ex-Muslim,
ex-Muslim and atheist from Kazakhstan.
So Kazakhstan is on the map as is
Kazakhstan's beloved neighbor
Usbekiststan.
I'm an ex-Muslim from Usuzbekiststan.
Thanks God Jesus Christ is only true and
way. Ex-Muslim from Usbekiststan.
Usbekiststan. Check. Now we've got
Malaysia. Ex-Muslim from Malaysia here
but still written Islam in our identity
card. No worries cuz our heart says we
are absolutely Christian. I live in
Malaysia. Convert to Christian about 15
years ago. I saw many Muslims decided to
get baptized to follow Jesus every
Easter Eve in my church. Malaysia,
ex-Muslim in Malaysia. Malaysia is on
the map. What about Somalia?
Ex-Muslim from Somalia. I'm a Somali
revert. I've reverted back to my
ancestors spirituality. No more Islam
for me. Thank you for all the work you
do. Ex-Muslim from Somalia. Ex-Muslim
from Somalia. in your face. Ilan Omar.
Next up, the Philippines. Ex-Muslim here
from the Philippines. I have so many
Muslim friends from the Philippines who
left Islam. Islam is dying in the
Philippines. Ex-Muslim from Philippines.
Jesus is the real Lord. Apostates just
put the Philippines on the apostate map.
But I bet you weren't expecting to hear
from Chetchna. I know one Chetchin
blogger and anti-Islam propagandist who
is also ex-Muslim and for the last 2
years he helped many Muslims from
Cauasus and Central Asia left that
cursed cult at least several hundred
people left that false faith but
unfortunately we don't have that many
anti-Islam propagandists in posts Soviet
countries I only know two bloggers that
dude and the second who is hiding his
identity out of fear before the most
peaceful religion. Think you'll be
getting some extra help soon. Chhatchan
ex-Muslim here. My people are waking up
and we already have public ex-Muslims,
anti-terror tree and radio Marshall.
Part of the ex-Muslim movement from
Chetchna since 2024. Now an atheist. So
we've got Cheschna. Can't click on
Chetchna because it's officially part of
Russia, but we see you there,
ex-Muslims. And we can't forget the
greatest country on earth, USA.
Ex-Muslim here from Hawaii. Aloha
snackbar. Alhamdulillah. I'm an Afghan
born in America. I converted to
Christianity in your Jesus versus
Muhammad days. The good old days.
Ex-Muslim from the USA. Pakistani
background for over 15 years. I became
Christian and found the true faith.
Plenty of apostates in the USA. And for
you maple syrup lovers, we have Canada.
Ex-Muslim from Canada, now a Christian.
God bless. I'm a Canadian who converted
to Islam. Left this year when I found
out about the death penalty for
apostasy. Always a good time to become
an apostate. Canadian-born Moroccan
here. Raised Muslim. Accepted Jesus
nearly a year ago. Thanks to you and
many others who do what you do. God
bless you, brother. Jesus is the way,
the truth, and the life. Canada is
finally on a map that matters. Let's
fill in a few more countries rapid fire.
Ex-Muslim from Sudan. Sudan. I'm
ex-Muslim from Tajikhstan. Tajikhstan.
Ex-Muslim from Poland here. Left Islam
and started following Hinduism a year
ago. Poland. Ex-Muslim from Russia.
Russia. Ex-Muslim from Yemen. Yemen.
ex-Muslim from Uganda with persecution,
beatings, disowning, no father, no
mother. Yet I have a big family all
around the world. I love Jesus Christ.
You first loved me and paid for my sins.
Now I am the righteousness of God.
Glory. Yes, the global church is your
family. Everyone be sure to read Mark
10:29-30.
Uganda. I am a former Muslim from Libya.
I'm currently an atheist, but I have no
problem with any religion except those
that impose themselves or call for
killing. That's what AP said when he was
an atheist. Libya. Ex-Muslim from
Bahrain. Bahrain. Ex-Muslim from Sagal.
Here, Sagal. Ex-Muslim from Sweden. Open
your heart to Jesus. Sweden. Ex-Muslim
from Kosovo. Kosovo. Ex-Muslim from
Ethiopia over 16 years. Praise the Lord.
Ethiopia, ex-Muslim from Kyrgystan.
Kyrgystan. I'm from Belgium. Used to be
an atheist and recently started visiting
my local Catholic church. The very first
person who greeted me there was called
Muhammad. Muhammad in Belgium. Ex-Muslim
from Tunisia. Tunisia. Ex-Muslim from
Denmark. Denmark. Ex-Muslim from France.
My family rejected me and said I am no
longer part of their family because I
rejected Islam. My brother who was Sunni
Salafi for 16 years of his life recently
converted to Eastern Orthodoxy. Praise
the Lord. Everyone read Mark 10:29-30
again. You have a way, way bigger family
than the one that rejected you. France,
[snorts] I'm an ex-Muslim from Kenya
thanks to the internet. I would like to
get baptized, but I can't do it because
of my family. When I'm old enough, then
I'll do that. Most of us young people in
Kenya don't really believe in Islam. But
since our families are deeply religious,
we just quietly leave the faith. Most of
my school friends don't even believe in
Islam anymore. Kenya. I know a
parishioner from our parish in Melbourne
who was a Pakistani Muslim is now
converted and baptized to Catholic.
Melbourne, guess we'll count this as
Australia. One of my friends who's a
Persian, married to a Hindu, both
converted to Christianity a few years
back before they decided to get married.
They wanted their wedding to be blessed
by God Almighty. Another agnostic friend
also started going to church with me for
the past 6 to seven months and she's
only missed maybe two services. It's
such a blessing and joy to witness and
pray for my agnostic friend to accept
Jesus and get baptized ASAP. God bless
you abundantly, David and others such as
AP. You've been a powerful voice on the
internet. Love from New Zealand. New
Zealand.
There were many, many more ex-Muslims in
the comment section of that one video,
but I've only included the ones who
named their countries so we could see
what this map looks like. These are just
some of the ex-Muslims who were watching
one particular video and left a comment.
How many more ex-Muslims are out there?
Seems like the avalanche of apostasy is
a real thing. We should get a huge wall
map and add to it whenever we hear from
ex-Muslims.
My friends, you are living at the
beginning of the golden age of apostasy
from Islam. We want to see the avalanche
accelerate. And every last one of you
can help. Learn about some of the
problems with Muhammad's character and
share what you learn. Take screenshots
of important quotes from their sources
and keep posting them. Learn the Islamic
dilemma. They can't answer it. And if
you're a Christian, make sure you can
defend the gospel.
Simple plan. Takes a little work, but as
you can see from our map here, it's all
worth it. Catch you guys next time.
[music]
>> [music]